There is a pattern to the introduction
of technologies.
When Gutenberg invented the press,
uh,
some of the earliest authors were
frightened of having their words and
thoughts set down permanently
distributed widely.
Jonathan Swift said that a book of
versus kept in a drawer showed only to
friends was like a,
a,
you know,
a fine lasts,
but once printed as a book,
it was like a common whore and you want
to,
can buy for two crown.
Fast forward to the,
the,
the prior kind of moral panic we've had
about privacy came because of the
technology in the year 1890,
the first major law review article
written by Louis Brandeis and said go
warren.
The tried to look for a legal basis to a
right to privacy in the United States
was inspired by the invention of a
technology,
the Kodak Camera,
and that caused some measure of moral
panic and fear.
The New York Times at the time has
stories about fiendish.
Kodak is lying in.
Wait,
a young vanderbilt,
a horse horsewhip,
a Kodak or a president.
Teddy Roosevelt outlawed Kodak,
him in Washington parks.
Now what happened?
Well,
we got used to cameras,
in fact,
we're happy to pose in front of them as
I am right now.
Uh,
and what really went on there was that a
new technology caused a change that our
norms weren't ready for.
And until such time as we had new norms,
we had new agreements about how we
operate as a society around this were
unsettled.
We're afraid of what could go wrong.
Well,
that's what's happening with the
Internet with a much bigger technology
that it is.
It's causing new opportunities.
It's causing change.
It also causes fear and disruption and
sometimes even a moral panic,
which is what I think we're going
through now.
Privacy matters.
Privacy is important.
That needs protectors.
I have a private life.
All that is true,
but we also have this magnificent tool,
the publicness,
the Internet in all of our hands.
We can find form and act as publix now
in ways that we couldn't before.
That's a magnificent ability and my fear
is that if governments come in to
regulate,
the net will lose some of that power and
some of them want us to lose that power
because they fear that power,
so I think we have to be aware of
demonizing technology,
things like tracking cookies,
being bad for us or worried about
technology first off,
because we're walking into the hands of
those who would limit the technology
rather than what we should do.
What society is long done is you
regulate the behaviors so you can use a
telephone to do good things and Simon
someone an ambulance,
you could use it to do bad things into
fraud.
People,
the technology isn't bad.
It's the behavior we regulate.
Yet nowadays we're seeing efforts by
governments to come in and regulate on
the whole the Internet,
so even Canada and Australia want to
filter all the content on the net to get
to pedophilia.
Well,
they create an ability and an
architecture that also Iran and China
will use.
We have to be aware of that.